I have a chapter on reasonable doubt and
it's about,
of course the phrase reasonable doubt
covers up in courts of law where juries
are told that they must convict somebody
of murder only if there is,
it's beyond reasonable doubt that they
are guilty.
And that sounds all very good.
It should be beyond reasonable doubt.
But when you think about the fact that I
think about courtroom dramas which are
so popular on television for example,
and I suspect that this accurately
portray something like what goes on in
real courtrooms.
And I've certainly been on three juries
myself.
There is a note of suspense in the court
when the jury comes back,
which way will it go?
Will it be guilty or not guilty?
And then if they say not guilty,
um,
certain people have a great sign of
relief if they say guilty,
other people do.
So there is a lot of doubt in the
courtroom among people who've sat
through the entire trial.
The judge,
for example,
the lawyers,
the audience sat through the entire
trial as the jewelry has.
So if the jury comes in and
brings in a verdict that is beyond
reasonable doubt,
everybody in the code should know that.
If it's beyond reasonable doubt,
there can be no doubt of which way the
jewelry we'll,
uh,
we'll jump.
And yet when the jewelry do give their
verdict,
because
how can that be if it's beyond
reasonable doubt?
Imagine the following experiment.
Suppose that you had two juries
listening to the same evidence and the
two juries not allowed to talk to each
other.
They are sent off into separate jury
rooms and they come up with their own
separate verdicts.
Who would bet on the jury's coming back
with the same verdict every single time.
But actually nobody would in my,
if you think about the Oj Simpson trial
or for example,
any 40,
based on another jury coming up with the
same verdict,
um,
and yet,
unless you can bet,
unless you can say yes,
they would come up with the same
verdict.
You cannot really take the phrase beyond
reasonable doubt.
Seriously.
Now,
I'm not suggesting that we should have
two juries in every trial.
I'm just pointing out that the phrase
beyond reasonable doubt,
it doesn't actually mean what it says.